so we had a life change in my last one
well my kids I want to share this video
you'll actually see them talking about
what happened to them I was about to buy
a publishing company I'm looking at five
different companies one of the companies
I'm looking at they said look before we
talk numbers I said send me some of the
books they send me 13 of them my son
reads every one of these books then all
of a sudden boom he comes up to me the
next day saying I want to go out there
and make money I don't want to mess up
the story I want you to hear it with all
of us in it then at the end I'll come
back and give you some final thoughts on
why this is important by the way if you
do get value from this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
here are my kids telling you what
happened last week so this is a chance
for me to brag about my kids a little
bit so what'd you guys do today what did
you make why is this a historic moment
you guys made the first twenty dollars
now why did you make twenty dollars was
it my idea it was my idea it was your
idea okay and when did you come up with
this idea when I read Thomas soul and I
read a book and I'm like that's a weird
job should get a job or something and
then what did you do right afterwards
you took immediate action on your own I
never told you to do anything where did
you go I told them so then you guys went
out in the city
now uh me Dylan answer when in the
community not knocking on doors and what
did you tell people I don't even know
what you guys so what'd you guys tell
them basically
hello we're here to help around the
house is there anything you need help
with and on the first time you guys went
did you make any money no okay so how
about today when you went out we won
yesterday twenty dollars and how did you
make twenty dollars not working you did
dog walking all of you you did the most
yes okay so whatever would have happened
without me so the CEO of the company
today is who okay who worked the hardest
today me so who gets out of the twenty
dollars what did I tell you guys what do
we do with the 20 of the month it's a
plenty of them but I said to you
whatever you make today I match you
right so this twenty dollars I'm Gonna
Keep because we're gonna frame it that
you guys made the first money ever we're
gonna call it the PDS and Associates
it's a company Patrick Dylan and Senna
and Associates I'm gonna match you
twenty dollars which means you guys made
forty dollars Tico you get 15 and then
you decided to do what
Dylan gets 50
and then some
Seneca stand for Biz death
congratulations to you guys shout out to
hat trick Billy and sales
and Ivana words
[Music]
I promise you I'm proud to trust me
you'll know in 20 years okay okay guys
say bye bye
all for 20 years you're gonna sit and
gonna love this video so how cool is
this video right I mean this is one of
my favorite videos because it's my kids
seeing them winning there's two things
that I want you to take away from this
video one I was 10 years old when I
realized I will never starve for the
rest of my life because I made my own
money in Germany at a refugee camp at a
local swimming pool and I came home
every day making money making money
making my life this is crazy if I can go
out there and do this I will never
starve but it happened to me
independently without my mom and dad's
family buying from me just like they
just made money without my friends and
family buying from them as a favorite
they did it on their own so number one
is learning how to never starve ever
again by making your money number two
you're one book away that was probably
his 600th book he's read all the other
books he read was biographies this is
the first book where he popped up and he
said I want to go make money I'm like
what I don't even know where this came
about until he did it afterwards then I
realized there's one book on Thomas Saul
inspired him to go out there and do this
so message number one when you learn how
to make your own money would I rely on
mommy and daddy you will never starve
for the rest of your life number two
when you find one book I can go back and
tell you 10 books that I read that were
life-changing in ways I can never
describe you because I had this one
question that it gave me so much Clarity
everything changed in my life whether
it's relationship selling leading
investing approach of Life any one of
that stuff because a book changed the
way I viewed one thing okay so if you
got value from this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
and I got another video for you to watch
it's a video I did titled 20 rules for
young men if you've never seen it before
click here to watch it take everybody
bye
foreign